[Music]
coming up next our live viewer call in
segment continues now with a discussion
of the current political situation in
chile we're joined by arturo valenzuela
the director of latin american studies
at georgetown university
[Music]
me
arturo valenzuela director of latin
american studies georgetown university
would you begin by telling us about the
elections or plebiscite that general
augusto pinochet shelly's ruler has
called for october 5th this is an
unusual election that's coming up in
chile on october 5th because it's a yes
or no vote
the chilean people will be given an
option
of either voting yes
in this election
and the a yes vote will mean that
president pinochet would remain in
office for another eight years
or if the chilean people decide to vote
no
it means that president binoche would
stay in office for another 12 months and
would then have to call for free
elections so it's a really important
turning point in the 15-year period of
military rule
in chile
are there polls in chile comparable to
ours in this country can you say
anything in a general way about what the
prospects appear to be for general
pinochet
well if the election were held today
it's likely that the opposition would
win that is that pinochet would lose we
do have in fact some polls and i brought
one today there's one that was taken in
august
and it showed that
among the electorate 40.6 percent would
vote no in the plebiscite that is they
would vote to reject pinochet's
candidacy for another years
and
30.6 percent would vote
yes that is they would vote in support
of the president the problem is that
there's a substantial number of people
who are still undecided apparently in
this election and we can talk about that
a little bit later on if you want
these it's not clear whether people are
undecided whether people might be afraid
whether people are concerned that that
their vote might in fact be discovered
and this is why they're not saying
exactly how they're going to vote in
fact one of the interesting things about
this poll is that people are asked how
many of you think that the
election would be a free election
and among these people
46.1 percent say that it would be a free
election
but 38.9 percent say that the election
would be fraudulent so people are really
worried about this plebiscite and not
sure exactly how they're going to vote
and what the outcome might be can you
make any projections
of what the effect on chile would be
economically and politically if
pinochet was eventually ousted from
office as a result of the plebiscite in
the following election
well this is a very complicated question
in fact what the government is arguing
today pinochet and his advisers
is that if in fact the chilean people
vote against president pinochet
then the economy in fact will suffer
enormously they argue that an opposition
victory would mean that chile would
return to the economic policies of the
past policies of
state intervention economy policies of
redistribution of income all of which
could damage their economic
program
the problem is that that it's not clear
that that would in fact happen because
the only thing that will happen if the
no vote wins in this plebiscite
is for
the chilean people to decide within 12
months
who they want to pick as a candidate the
no vote in chile and the october 5th
plebiscite means open elections within a
year
and the chilean people could then decide
to vote in fact for
a conservative candidate they would
follow the same kinds of economic
policies that the financial regime has
followed this far
what is the current state of chile's
economy compared the recent period
well the the chilean economy
uh has recovered substantially recently
in fact it's done uh quite well if you
compare it with the economies of other
countries in latin america and in the
third world as a whole
the fiscal deficit
has disappeared the reserves are rather
substantial
exports
are up the chilean the unemployment is
still high but it's lower than it was
before
the chilean economic planners have done
a good job despite the fact that there's
a huge
foreign debt in chile of about 20
billion dollars they've done a good job
compared with their
their neighbors there's a cost however
and this is something that the
government is going to have to
take into account in their projections
on the plebiscite and that is that the
economic picture has not necessarily
included a significant amount of income
distribution
and wages for example are still quite
low
uh as compared with what they were
before so that that it's a it's a
problem for the for the government
our guest is arturo valenzuela director
of latin american studies at georgetown
university you've been in that position
i believe for about one year previously
taught at duke university you're
originally from chile born in chile
you have written extensively on chile
and you were in
your native country only last week
would you take us back 15 years and set
the stage as many americans may recall
it perhaps dimly when general pinochet
overthrew the government of salvador
yendi
we need to remember that the
coup
the military coup that brought
the
government of pinochet into power in
1973
came after a period of about three years
of a socialist government
chile unlike many of the other countries
in latin america had a very very long
tradition of democratic rule
and president allende was elected in
1970 as a socialist to the presidency of
the country
he attempted with his supporters to try
to carry out
very far-reaching
socio-economic transformations in the
country
and of course these transformations were
opposed by a significant sector of the
chilean society
the problem is that the country fell
into a real log jam a real uh contest
between the supporters of allende that
wanted to press for these reforms
some who wanted to press for the reforms
at all cost others who argued that it
was important to have these reforms only
within the democratic framework that
chile had experienced for many
generations
what happened was that
by the time 1972 came along
the opposition to the regime was very
very significant and the armed forces
became quite disenchanted with the
regime
and so on september 11 1973 the military
as a whole
decided to move against the allende
government supported by a substantial
portion of the chilean people
it uh it was a controversial move
many in chile then argued that these
issues should be resolved not through a
military intervention but through
democratic processes
but in a sense the
the
confrontation had run its course and the
military decided to move in and
overthrow an elected government
we'll be going to the phones in just a
couple of minutes the numbers in the
eastern and central time zone area 202
628-2525 in the mountain and pacific
time zones 202
there were extensive senate hearings in
this country after the overthrow of the
agenda government that all happened 14
or 15 years ago too can you take us back
to that period and tell us a little
about those hearings
well the hearings that dealt with
the chilean situation
included several
incidents
of u.s involvement in chilean affairs
it uh some hearings dealt for example
with the role of the private sector
in in the chilean political situation
notably uh the
intervention of the international
telephone and telegraph company
attempting to
to
produce some kind of a change of regime
they were quite concerned that the
chilean government and the chilean
under again they would be detrimental to
the interests of international business
until their own to their own interests
and so they attempted to
to pursue certain kinds of uh policies
destabilizing policies of the regime the
second set of hearings dealt much more
directly with the role of the united
states central intelligence agency in
attempting again to affect internal
affairs in chile
in indeed the united states
from orders directly from from the white
house did attempt
in 1970 to prevent the election of
president allende after he was elected
an attempt was made to derail his
assuming power
and then later on the united states
covertly and overtly did support
elements of the opposition during the
agenda years this was a controversial
issue at the time in the united states
i would say to finish the point that
it's
it's certainly not
true that the united states was
the most important factor and the
overthrow of the government many people
in this country and abroad and chile
itself think that this impact was the
case
it was a factor but it certainly wasn't
the most important fact
one of the surprise developments of
recent weeks has been the action taken
by general uh pinochet
who uh in effect uh
lifted the restrictions on the return of
exiles or most exiles who were living
abroad to chile can you tell us about
that
well after the coup took place in 1973
tens of thousands of chileans left the
country
many were quite afraid that they
would not be able to survive and others
lost jobs and others
simply
could not continue living in in the
country under military rule
um
over the years
the government has lifted some of the
restrictions on on exiles so that today
they're only a really a relatively small
number of exiles who are still formally
barred from the country although many
people are still worried about returning
because they fear for
personal safety however the number of
individuals who were officially barred
before he lifted this ban on exiles or
this uh before he permitted the exiles
to come back was was only a few hundred
individuals
it can be read
in one of two ways on the one hand it
can be read as a magnanimous gesture
which
was applauded by the international
community and i think rightly so
it could also be read however
more cynically in political terms as an
attempt on the part of the government to
remind chilean voters that many of the
people who will be coming back now for
example some of the top leaders of the
communist party have been living in
moscow for the last 15 years to remind
these people that these individuals were
involved in the government of salvador
allende and in fact their presence uh
should remind them that maybe they
should vote for this government to
continue pinochet's rule
we're going to take our first telephone
call in just a moment i will remind our
callers uh first please stay on the line
when you hear your telephone call
ringing if you don't
we may lose you i think we lost one call
in the previous
show so we'll take our first call now
from clearwater florida go ahead please
yes um my question is about the foreign
debt situation in brazil
and drawing kind of a parallel or maybe
a reverse parallel with the chilean
government
the fledging democracy of brazil is
struggling maybe strangling under a
foreign debt
with a lot of social upheaval which in
effect could put down the democracy in
the long run and the military really
does seem to be behind the president who
is not an elected president and credo
died and the new president sarnae is not
an elected president and if the
gentleman mr
valenzuela can draw a parallel with that
situation and see any dangers in the
democracy in brazil
well i think that that to refer very
briefly to the brazilian situation
clearly the economic situation and the
situation of the debt in brazil is has
been a great burden for the brazilian
democracy and brazil is
in significant trouble today
because of
the the debt and a general economic
crisis
uh to return to the chilean case
in chile you have a very large debt as
well
however the chilean government and this
is to its credit has been able to manage
its economic policies quite well
and the debt situation at this point is
not a serious problem
however i must remind our viewers that
this economic management has also taken
a cost as i said earlier and that is a
cost uh of austerity policies that have
led to
to
a situation where many people in the
lower and
middle classes have seen their
purchasing power reduced significantly
in this period so
the belt tightening has worked in some
ways and chile is in better situation in
terms of its macro economic policy
but the belt tightening has also had a
social cost it's really rather
significant
are chile's relations with the united
states an issue in the country's
forthcoming plebiscite
in a sense uh the relations with the
united states are an issue
in the forthcoming plebiscite but
perhaps not for the reasons that we
might all think
the the real issue
in relationships with the united states
is that the chilean government the
government of general pinochet has taken
strong exception
to
the policy of the united states of
encouraging chile toward to move towards
a fuller and more open and freer
democratic process
this has been a policy that's been
pursued by the united states now for the
last
three years
at least and the reaction of the chilean
government has been to accuse the united
states of intervention
in domestic affairs of chile an
unwarranted
intervention
in their view
which is a bit ironic i guess because
the united states did intervene on the
side of some of these same people
earlier when the allende government was
overthrown
the opposition i should say however
which might very well win this
plebiscite it's not clear yet
the opposition on the other hand i think
has been rather pleased that the united
states has taken a strong position on
democratic transformation in the chilean
case greensboro north carolina please
join us
hello hi
um i was wondering
if he had any information on why senator
helms here in north carolina
is supporting the dictatorship in chile
what is in it for senator helms
to take that position if anything
well i think that
senator helms has
simply is mistaken
in his appreciation of the chilean
situation now i
let me make very clear that there are a
lot of chileans of course that support
president pinochet as well much of the
business community supports president
dinesha many people applaud the fact
that he has conducted
economic policies that have led to a
significant recovery
so it's
we should not give the impression that
large numbers of chileans are opposed to
this government although i'm quite sure
that a great majority is in fact with
the opposition now
i think that what's happened is that
senator helms has has uh
viewed president pinochet first and
foremost as an anti-communist and he has
provided him with strong support in that
regard and feels that the continuation
of an individual like president pinochet
in chile is a guarantee against the
resurgence of
a socialist or a communist left
however i should add that many people
who are conservatives and self-described
conservatives in chile don't necessarily
hold that view
in fact i would venture to say that
privately most of the chilean
political leaders on the right today
would have preferred to have another
candidate other than pinochet stand
for this plebiscite
pinochet was selected by the four
commanders of the armed forces to stand
in this plebiscite they were the only
ones that could select the candidate
and many people on the right until they
have been urging the four commanders to
select another person
on the view that eight more years of a
pinochet government could have a
seriously destabilizing effect on the
country
a good deal was written about alleged
human rights violations in chile back in
the 1970s when the congressional
investigations were going on in this
country
is there anything current can you give
us an appraisal of human rights
conditions in chile today
well i would i guess i would say that
and in some respects human rights
conditions have improved uh
significantly in the last
few months and certainly if you go back
to the period after 1973 74 75 we don't
have the kinds of
significant violations of human rights
there was a period in the 1970s 74 75
and 76
where people were systematically
picked up
and tortured and then disappeared
without any kind of trial
and
many chileans abhor this because they
understand that
no matter what your crime might have
been or what the accusations are against
you in a civilized society you
have to
be tried under
the rules of due process and of course
this didn't take place then
there are some some elements of concern
however for
human rights today for example let me
give you one uh
the press uh in chile up until recently
has been
circumscribed there are something like
30 journalists right now who are under
indictment or have been charged with
violating certain kinds of security laws
for publishing materials
that they that the government has viewed
to be
against national security considerations
and this is a a violation i guess of
human rights and there's been a campaign
recently of
of intimidation of
people
people have received threats
some people have been picked up
and this is this has created a climate
of of some
uh concern
however the sort of
massive arrests tortures and
disappearances that that are associated
with an earlier policy
have now changed
president jimmy carter of course put a
great deal of emphasis on
human rights and
and an effort to explore human rights
violations in
other countries
what is the attitude of the united
states government today to avoid human
rights abuses in chile
the
united states government
as you rightly point out under the
carter administration became very
concerned about the violations of human
rights in chile
there are several incidents in chile
that
that raised international
outcry
at the same time
an incident that occurred in the city in
washington d.c
led to
severely strained relations between the
united states and chile and that was the
assassination of orlando lettilier the
former
u.s and bachelin ambassador the united
states and also foreign minister under
the undergovernment
so the relationships under the carter
administration with the chilean
government became extremely strained a
court here
asked for the extradition of the head of
the chilean security police who was
implicated in the assassination of mr
letalier the chilean government denied
his extradition
and that has that issue still has not
been resolved now when the reagan
administration came into office
at first there was a significant
improvement in the relationships with
the
with the pineal government the argument
the reagan administration was that you
had to tolerate
military governments that they
it might in fact be beneficial under
certain circumstances certainly much
better than governments that's veer much
to the left so there was a cordial
relationship with the pinochet
government at first this however changed
as well
about three or four years ago
when massive riots broke out in chile
and when many people on the political
right in chile began to think that the
continuation of the pinochet government
could in fact be detrimental
to
democratic stability in the future and
might in fact
uh encourage the development
of a stronger communist opposition
los angeles california please join us
yes um
yoga and your guests mentioned earlier
that
many people inside chile overestimated
the role of the cia in the group that
toppled allende
um
i was wondering uh what does he think
are the strengths of anti-american
sentiments in chile and secondly
are there many people in chile who
believe in
dependency type theories where they
think the u.s is basically responsible
for most of the things that happen sir
well i as i said earlier uh one of the
ironies of the current situation
is that the people who are most
concerned about u.s intervention
in chile today are people who are
supporting this government i went to a
pro-government rally a couple of weeks
ago and one of the most important
leaders of the
political right that is supporting the
pinochet government gave a very strong
and very anti-american speech so if
there is anti-americanism in some way
it's among those sectors that are now
supporting the military regime who have
objected to the united states argument
that democracy would be in fact a better
system for chile and chile should move
faster towards the democratic process
among the opposition however
which might have been more anti-american
before
including many sectors of the what you
might call moderate socialists there's a
greater i guess acceptance and
and
a favorable view of the united states
today because of the human rights
stands the united states has taken which
you mentioned earlier
you mentioned that you had attended a
pro-government rally uh recently in
chile tell us a little as you return to
chile having been born there raised
there as you return now as a student of
chile
and
relations between chile and the united
states what do you do who do you talk
with in chile do you
roam around the country or what well
what i do when i go to chile is to
in fact touch base with with almost
everyone
i
have a very close friends and colleagues
in every sector of the chilean political
spectrum on the political right
on the marxist left
in the christian democratic center
people that i've known over the years
and uh who with whom i've had interviews
at great length uh
often
and this puts me in a relatively good
position i think to judge the pulse of
the country but what i did this last
time which was particularly interesting
for me
was not only to speak to political
leaders
union leaders party officials and so on
whom i've known now for some time but
also try to go out into the country and
get
a taste for
the feelings and the views of ordinary
people and i have an advantage in that
my wife is a
foreign correspondent for the boston
globe
and
she
is very skillful at this sort of
interview and we went out together into
many neighborhoods in santiago as well
as in the southern part of the country
just to talk to ordinary people
and that was maybe more enlightening
because often
if you speak to the leaders they give
you their point of view but it doesn't
necessarily
give you what
the folks
who are going to be voting
feel do you feel that you and your wife
the foreign correspondent have complete
freedom to talk with anyone you'd like
to talk with in chile and that they have
complete freedom to talk to you
well i think things have changed
recently chile began a liberalization
process after 1983
something of an opening
it was certainly much more difficult to
speak to people
ordinary people as well as as leaders in
the in the 1970s 1975 76 where there was
a a much
greater sense of
of tension
much and still a feeling of conflict
within the country but today it is
easier to do that
and
we found however
and this is a i think an important point
and it relates to some of the surveys
that have been coming out about the
plebiscite we found
that people in
working class
neighborhoods and in outlying
neighborhoods and shanty towns
were worried about talking to people who
were coming from outside
and they were worried because they felt
that maybe they were being monitored in
some way
in some cases i i know that they felt
that that maybe we represented some
official
group
and then we were coming to try to find
out how they felt about these things so
initially they were very reticent to
talk to us
but after a while for the most part
people tend to warm up
people are very charitable and very
friendly
in chile and we had wonderful
conversations with people ranging from
taxi drivers to street sweepers to
unemployed workers
just to get a sense for what they they
felt
pleasantville new york go ahead please
yes hello hi
uh the american
liberal mass media called alien the
democrat you call him a socialist but it
seems to me he was a pro communist
and my question is
if he continued his policy
wouldn't he hear second uh
ortega or castro
yes more often in this country referred
to as a marxist so would you include
that in your answer
well this is a complicated uh subject
because we get into
semantical
definitional problems
allende was himself
he referred to himself as a marxist and
so i guess that's
a fair way of characterizing him he was
also a member of the socialist party so
he identified himself
as a socialist
however it is my view when i actually
wrote a book about the breakdown of
democracy in chile it's my view that
allende
who participated as a congressman and as
a senator for many many many years in
chilean politics was firmly convinced
that he would be able to bring about
fundamental social transformations
within a democratic framework that in
fact he he wouldn't have to deviate from
the rules and procedures that would set
up for a liberal democracy in order to
bring about socialist transformations
he ran into difficulty as we know
and some people may have questioned his
motives but i don't think the record
shows
that he was somebody who was
significantly against democratic
procedures
des moines iowa please join us
yes um
i was warning uh what is your opinion mr
venezuela as to whether
um what is your opinion as far as
the new county government if are you
more favoring the left leaning or the
right leaning i mean what would you
think would be best for chile
i also like to ask them if your answer
is yes
uh what kind of uh
we'll call it left-leaning we'll call it
communist governments uh can you name
where you know as an example where you
know the chili should follow that is a
good example as far as free press
and uh you're talking about civil rights
you know and and the people being afraid
to come back because they think that
maybe the government is
monitoring them monitoring them and
that's a very
uh
very likely thing to happen
in most communist societies i just
wondering what is your personal opinion
as to which
form of government left or rightly that
you would be in favor of
well i don't have any problem whatsoever
in in stating my bias loudly and clearly
and my bias is towards democrat
democratic government democratic
procedures
i feel that uh chile with its long
tradition of democratic practices
could today very easily
move into
a democratic form of government and that
the country would be run relatively well
by
the political elite in that country let
me tell you a little bit about what the
chilean
people think about this question they
were asked in this recent national poll
that was taken in august
uh what is best for the country if the
yes wins or if the no wins that is if
the yes wins
supporting pinochet whether no wins
the position of the opposition
34 percent say that if it would be
better for the country if the yes wins
41.9 percent or 50 say that it would be
worse for the country the yes wins they
would prefer the no
as to whether the country would be
better off with a socialist government
or
with a conservative government
let me
say there that i would
like to see open and free elections in
chile so the chilean people themselves
can decide which kind of option they
ought to take my own view would be the
chile needs
perhaps moderate
policies uh in in the near future
policies they will address some of the
social
uh injustices that exist in the country
but at the same time policies that are
that are responsible enough that that
you would be able to continue to see the
trends of economic growth that have been
going on in the country in the last few
years
uh we
asked you or a caller asked you to talk
about the
labels you would
put on the
yandi government when he was in power
could you do the same thing for the
pinochet government would you call him a
right extreme right authoritarian or
what
i guess authoritarian is maybe the best
way to call him
he is
a military man president pinochet
he is still the commander-in-chief of
the army
in fact according to the constitution
he will
continue to be commander-in-chief of the
army if the no vote wins this is sort of
a paradoxical situation he loses the
election that is coming up
he would still continue for at least
four more years commander chief of the
army he's very much of a military man
i don't think he has too much sympathy
for democratic politics
and as such i guess authoritarian is the
best
label
encino california go ahead please yes
thank you i just want to make a
quick comment i was recently in chile
i'm a businessman and it was when i was
there
after several meetings with some
outstanding individuals in the academic
community
and some very aggressive young business
people and i'm in the communication
business and i won't mention names or
anything i noticed that i wasn't alone
after my second meeting
my driver was stopped in question
i think my phones were tapped um i even
had a visit an impromptu visit from some
individual who i suspect was in the
central intelligence agency
i think in chile now today is still
repressive there's still a great deal of
paranoia but as i agree with the
gentleman uh they're more discreet far
more uh i think secretive about who they
target and who they may
say whisk off in the night so to speak
things have changed but uh not a heck of
a lot i just want to hang up and listen
to this guy caller while you're still on
the line uh did you feel in any personal
peril while you were in chile no i
didn't feel any personal peril at all i
felt very very uncomfortable um because
i don't think uh
that
they they knew exactly what my aims were
on my goals they all only knew my
business intentions uh but you do feel
very very uncomfortable there's a
feeling that you can't even describe in
words uh and i think the gentleman will
could articulate that more than i could
thank you
thank you for your comment
well um
let me say that i've also spoken to many
other people who've had an experience
like he has who felt somewhat
uncomfortable
in going to chile but i've also spoken
to many people
and perhaps some of the viewers
who are watching today will have this
other experience of going to chile
and finding people to be very open and
very free businessmen in particular go
to chile and often they don't see the
other side of the picture
they see a country that is prospering
they see a country that that
seems to be doing extremely well and a
people it is very uh
in some ways very satisfied much of the
business community as i said earlier
supports this government and feels that
this government has done great things
for them
the story is more complicated when you
get into small villages and when you get
when you speak to people who are
associated with
parties of the left
i myself i should say
without any hesitation i've been going
back to chile now since
1979 on a on a regular basis two or
three times a year and i've never felt
any
difficulty despite the fact that i've
had contacts with people across the
political spectrum you mentioned the
chilean business community how about the
american business community american
firms doing business in chile we had an
example of that 15 years ago with itt
but today do you think most american
corporations would prefer to see the
pinochet government remain in power
i think my impression is that there are
some american corporations that have
thought of investing in chile that have
been worried about the political
prospects i think there is uh
a legitimate political risk issue
in relationship to chile uh
in the next few years
particularly if the yes uh is
confirmed and if pinochet is in power
for another eight years
i do foresee uh considerable
confrontation and polarization in the
country and this could
lead to a situation where the business
climate deteriorates rather
significantly
but my impression has been that
u.s businessmen for the most part who
have opted for investing in chile
have been relatively pleased with
the kinds of returns that they've been
getting
we'll take our last call from hampton
virginia go ahead please
um yes basically my question is even if
pinochet is defeated in this election
according to the 1980 uh
constitution he's become a senator for
life playing a key role in appointing
other members in a new 36-man senate so
basically
he's never
actually going to lose his control in
politics is he
uh
the caller is right that the
constitution
prescribes several roles for pinochet
even if he loses
the election not only will he
be a senator for life as
commander-in-chief of the army which he
would not give up he would also be a
member of the national security council
which is a body that is envisioned in
the chilean constitution that has a
right to admonish
any other
body in the
in the chilean institutional framework
including the congress or the president
if it feels that the president or the
congress or whatever
body is being admonished is violating
national securities and this is a very
important
role in the sense that pinochet has
safeguarded for himself however i really
do feel that if the no vote wins in
chile
even if pinochet
tries to remain as a senator
and particularly if after the no vote
wins the opposition is able to win the
presidency and a majority in the
congress the chilean political situation
will change such that there really won't
be a role anymore for somebody like
president pinochet in the politics of
the country
among the exiles who returned to chile
recently at the invitation and effect of
the pnsa government
was isabella yendi the daughter of
salvador allende and she was returning
to the country for the first time in 15
years since her
father's murder
does that have any political
implications
i think it might um
have some political implications uh it
is symbolic of a change uh in the
country
it means that many people who did
support the agenda government and
remember allende was elected with 36.2
percent of the vote
and by the 1973 congressional election
his supporters had received almost 50
percent of the vote
a lot of people do
think of salvador allende as a great man
and certainly the return of his daughter
to chile will
will
please many of the people that
supported him
i should say however that the there's
been a substantial change in the
socialist party in chile you find that
there are sectors in the socialist party
that that have a more much more moderate
view of the role of of
a leftist in even a marxist party in
politics so i don't think the policies
is going to be the same
our guest tonight has been arturo
valenzuela director of latin american
studies at georgetown university and an
expert on chile thank you very much for
being with us thanks to our c-span
viewers for your questions and comments
have a pleasant evening
[Music]
if you have additional questions for our
guest arturo valenzuela from georgetown
university you can write to him at the
latin american studies program at
georgetown washington dc the zip code is
two zero zero five seven
[Music]
you